good morning everyone
my name is dr. Miller and ASCP were
going to be looking at today
his SCP 846 object class safe special
containment procedures SCP 846 is to be
contained in a reinforced steel safe
located in storage units its site SCP
846 s containment area is to be guarded
by three security personnel at all times
any unauthorized personnel attempting to
access SCP 846 are to be taken into
custody and interrogated by on-site
security activation of SCPA 46 must be
authorized by at least three level 4
personnel any testing of scp-804 t 6 is
to take place at an on-site firing range
description SCP 846 is a plastic toy
robot measuring 20 centimeters in height
and 5 centimeters in width the bottom of
scp-804 t 6 is right foot bears the text
robo dude registered trademark
now with voice command action by dr
wonder tainment signs of paint chipping
and minor damage to SCP 846 indicate
that it is roughly ten years old
although attempts to question a CP 846
on this have been ignored see interview
846 one SCP 846 is operated using a
small controller featuring an on/off
button a speak button and a small
microphone SCP a46 is activated using
the on/off button and verbal
communication can be facilitated using
the speak button SCP 846 appears to be
extremely well program if not sentient
and will respond to most questions posed
to it
as CP 846 identifies itself as Robo dude
and claims that it possesses 350 Robo
accessories when asked to use one of
these accessories the torso of scp-804
t6 slides open revealing the desired
accessory which it then proceeds to
utilize the interior of SCPA 46 appears
to change completely each time it is
asked to utilize an accessory as CP 846
seems to be unable to utilize these
accessories without being instructed to
do so
SCP 846 has claimed to possess among
other things a fire drill tested
functioned as a flamethrower an energy
laser tested functioned as a pistol a
boom ray tested functioned as a rocket
launcher a melty Tron 5000 tested
sprayed acid at target a ultra plasma
rifle tested functioned as an assault
rifle a hydrogen cannon tested
functioned as a children's water gun bug
spray
tested released unidentified organisms
that consumed the wooden target a ray
gun tested released a stream of gamma
radiation an atomic grenade testing
strictly forbidden history SCP 846 was
brought into containment after an
unknown individual delivered it in a
sealed package to a front company for
the SCP foundation the label of the
package simply read Merry Christmas
agents upon learning of scp-804 t 6 is
unusual properties inform their
superiors as CP a 46 was subsequently
taken into Foundation custody
the following is interview 840 6-1
interviewed SCP 846 interviewer dr.
playing log instructions including any
attempt to open or service Robidoux is
likely to result in unpredictable
behavior doctor wonder tainment is not
liable for any damage destruction or
loss of personal or real property or for
any injury including to the honor the
operator or others which may result from
the operation Robidoux functions by
interacting rhonu in any way or my
remaining it relatives presence in five
seconds following the completion of this
announcement you accept the terms and
conditions described in this
announcement as amended and supplemented
by dr. wonder came from time to time
with her before or after acceptance and
agreed to hold blameless dr wonder
tainment
and everyone else affiliated with dr
wonder tainment from and against all
liability or losses relating to Robo
dude dr. wonder Taemin reserves all
rights and remedies including but not
limited to intellectual property rights
and to relative role pal Robo
accessories and all patents trademarks
copyright and other intellectual
properties embedded or embody therein
greetings robopal hello SCP 846 how are
you functioning full capacity robopal
that's nice
I just like to ask you a few questions
SCP 846
where were you produced do is the
intellectual property of dr. Wonder
Taemin alright
when were you made Robin do is the
intellectual property of dr. Wonder
tainment okay yes she peered 46 dude
please refer to Robin do as Rama do no
please tell me about yourself
SCP 846 this version of Robidoux is
equipped with over a hundred new Robo
accessories and Roma features included
voice action
punch and Robo dad's Rumble dude will
now demonstrate Robo dads
no thank you scp-826 I'd like to at this
point scp-826 began a Robo dance which
lasted 23 minutes at CP 846 ignored all
questions during this time period are
you finished
Robo dance is complete
how do you access new weapons as CP 846
there is no way that could all fit
inside of you is equipped with interior
ship in a bit of new global feature from
dr. winter tainment interesting how are
you responding to my questions have you
been programmed to do so is the
intellectual property of doctor 1
detainment SCP 846 tell me why you are
able to respond to questions do not
intimidate Romelu alright
this concludes our lecture for today
thank you all for listening and you were
all dismissed
good bye man I gotta get me one of those
that'd be fun right
I would like to give a special thank you
to Andre Pichette Pierce M Hamlin Muslim
Wookiee Jax Marik
Caleb Bowen slump God John Porter
captain Gorge diver ball Cody tench
cheese whip dips McGee on dr. mortis
like eels so much for your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos found some other cool
stuff as well go to patreon.com/scishow
[Music]
you